the Joe Rogan experience so you have
such a huge responsibility here you know
that obviously but but because you have
so many people watching this show okay
and kind of freaked me out Tom Crean
little it's all you're responsible
you're responsible for me doing this how
about that so ultimately you I don't
like your kid yeah you know for Patrice
used to say that about comedians that
like imitated him they're my babies
Patrice you say like like David tells
got a lot of babies out there because a
lot of people imitating David tell but
you have a lot of babies and I'm one of
your babies how about that that's very
nice of you to say I
that's hilarious Terence Mckenna your
baby that is very kind of you to say I'm
sitting here on your incredible show
with everybody is riveted by your show
and when you say something it matters
which is different than when you do a
show on your you know I do a podcast now
I got a few people listening but it's
not like it doesn't matter right that's
a responsibility
so it's a responsibility of the people
listening but you're when you say
something here it will affect the entire
society you have people now who don't
believe in stay home order their own
well they should they should they should
until the actual scientific experts tell
them that they should go out but here's
the thing right who are the experts and
are they different in different states
and I think that's one of the benefits
of having 50 states when I was talking
about the different styles of living
Arizona lets you have a gun just carried
on your hip right you can't do that in
San Francisco right everyone there's
different styles of living let's find
out what different styles are right way
to reopen the world we know the world's
got to be reopened okay we're not gonna
just stay in our house forever we're
gonna run out of food I have to do
things right so do we have to do things
after the vaccination and can our
society survive that do you know many
people are committing suicide right now
my yeah
friend of mine was her said nick
swardson I said yesterday sorry dang he
told me was talking to the sheriff and
the sheriff said they used to deal with
one suicide a week now they're doing
five a day this is something needs to be
factored in right other thing there's a
there's a Bloomberg there was an article
that was written that we're talking
about the drop in the economy equivalent
to a loss of a certain number of lives
and that every time the economy drops a
certain percentage that's equal to X
amount of lives we might get to a place
where it's conceivable that more lives
are lost because of the ensuing
depression an economic shutdown then
where would have been lost if we didn't
open up if we didn't close that anything
and we just let everybody get sick it's
a it is a complicated thing and this is
one thing that we have to really rely on
the people that are supposed to be in
power to address accurately and honestly
no one knows the right way to do this
there's some real good protocols in
place for four P keeping people healthy
and protecting each other and staying
away from each other as much as possible
and wiping thing down and using hand
sanitizer and stopping the spread yes
for sure but no one knows how to get
this thing started again no one knows
what's gonna happen knows no one knows
what the risks are are we gonna wait and
in the meantime what about the other
diseases that are still around what
about the colds and the flu and what
about all that stuff that all stuff that
you know it kills more people than any
of these things including kovat 19
projections heart attacks yeah heart
attacks killing people left and right
how come there's no like well there's no
alarms to stop people from dying of
heart attacks heart disease was number
one like the flu and all these other
things that we're all terrified of this
is lack of know first of all lack of
information not knowing I mean lack of
you don't know if you can prevent this
right cannot you can't you know you know
you've eat well you didn't you look
after yourself you less likely to have a
heart attack but you don't know if you
can breathe can't breathe then a heart
and then the heart attack thing is all
dependent upon your genetics as well
there's some people that have a
predisposition to heart attacks but what
you know like again noticed I guess I
asked this already but like that's a lot
of pressure
I mean because if you say something
wrong and it's sending people so you
must do I'm just kind of curious how
much time you do spend researching
because you know you know so much
information my ass 99% of the time you
have Jamie Google things to correct me
in midstream
so is it instinct is that are you able
to see sort of the you know the the
truth through the [ __ ] and then you
kind of because cuz I mean please sort
it out in real time cuz you're walking a
very you're walking a very fine line
then you I think you're walking and
incredibly well and in a way that many
many many great many people are not
right they true it seems like we're in
this world now where because
everything's so polarized oh I've got to
choose to say this because that's what
everyone's saying and they're just kind
of saying it because everyone's saying
it whereas you definitely straddle that
line in a way that to me seems
incredibly astute but also must be some
pressure to make sure that you're right
not until you start telling me about it
freaking out Tom Green well because you
could easily be you could easily be hey
you should this is [ __ ] I told him
he was my daddy
now cuz being he's being like now he's
he's basically giving me the hard
conversation I'm curious because it's
fascinating to me thank you how do I do
it yeah how do you help you make those
determinations because a lot of people
have made mistakes right a lot I'm a lot
of commentators have made mistakes who
have said things I make mistakes too if
you're doing 1500 whatever the [ __ ]
shows plus fight companions and [ __ ]
I don't know Jerry MMA shows there's
another 50 of those at least right mhm
100 Jesus we're living the world now any
mistake they've already done that that's
okay go ahead keep going do it again
it's this like number the vast number of
interactions that most people have with
each other are positive right most of
the other wise the world be a war zone
most of the time you're dealing people
like a I do and hey what's up hey
there's the same thing with podcast
vast majority of the the stuff he do is
gonna be good it's gonna be moments
where the some guy you were taking a
left turn and he hawked you and you said
[ __ ] you and he said no [ __ ] you and
like that guy's got a bad opinion you
you got a bad opinion him that's gonna
happen to well that's the same in
podcast it's gonna be these moments
where things just just fall apart or go
off the rails
it's got accepted it is what it is and
how do you decide to not and I I don't
feel like you do have an agenda to
change or change things in any sort of
premeditated direction you just you're
trying to beyond what people don't want
everyone has an agenda right you say
this road see Pelosi you you say this
about who everyone right-left right-left
they got an agenda oh I can't say this
even though I believe it because that's
not going to work with the narrative
right that seems crazy I don't have an
agenda yeah yeah no I can tell you just
want to be real well I just I wanted I
just want to be able to talk to friends
about stuff that's actually happening
that's it you know but if you haven't
liked the agentive an agenda at all is I
want people to do better you me included
I mean there's one of the things that I
like to do I was possible at this point
sure for sure you do everything real
stand-up with archery yeah I get better
at playing pool tomorrow practice okay
maybe get better at pool maybe doing
martial arts or like the more you do it
the more you think about how you're
doing it and more you realize like oh
there's like a lot of stuff I could
learn here uh-huh that's what I want
people to do I want people to find
things and try to get better at them
doesn't mean try to be the best doesn't
mean be obsessed with it there's
something that you get out of trying to
be better
[Applause]